a long line of ambulances queued outside
a New York Hospital and officials say
the peak of the pandemic has still not
been reached it's not expected to hit
the city for several more days against
the backdrop of the most deadly day
since a virus hit the US president Trump
continued his feud with the World Health
Organization accusing it of initially
minimizing the threat of the virus and
responding sharply to that agency's
director-general who said that
politicizing the virus could lead to
more body bags when you say more body
bags I think we would have done and he
would have been much better serving the
people that he's supposed to serve if
they gave a correct analysis I mean
everything was I said China centric
everything was gonna be fine
no human-to-human keep the borders open
he wanted me to keep the borders open I
closed the borders despite him and that
was a hard decision to make at the time
we're all together we made a decision
against the World Health Organization I
can't believe he's talking about
politics when you look at the
relationship they have to China so China
spends 42 million we spend 450 million
and everything seems to be China's way
that's not right it's not fair to us and
honestly it's not fair to the world at
this point we're reading our funding
with respect to the World Health
Organization now this is very consistent
what President Trump said since the
beginning of his campaign organizations
have to work they have to deliver the
outcomes for which they were intended
president Trump continued to endorse the
use of the anti malaria drug
hydroxychloroquine ignoring the warning
by many specialists that unsourced
medical advice could prove dangerous
zinc they say is ink you should add zinc
now so has to be recommended by doctors
physicians but they say zinc I want to
throw that out there because that's
where they seem to be having the best
result and while the president was
volunteering anecdotal medical advice
New York City continued its preparations
for what is
to come volunteers setting up a field
hospital in a downtown Church hoping
against all predictions that it will not
be needed Mike Hanna al Jazeera
Washington